dans le vendée globe challenge la course
en solitaire autour du monde l'un des
concurrents bertrand de broc vient de
vivre une bien pénible mésaventure au
large de l'antarctique une écoute de
voix lui a frappé violemment le visage
résultat un oeil tuméfié et la langue
profondément coupée pour éviter
l'infection
le navigateur a dû lui même se poser des
points de suture sur instruction
médicales venues par télex patrice
romedenne tout commence par ce fax j'ai
la langue coupée
je saigne ainsi bertrand de broc alerte
le médecin de la course débute alors une
consultation par télex ou le patient
dans les 50e à bord de son monocoque
groupe lg applique à la lettre les
consignes du médecin basé en vendée
extrait du dialogue le médecin ouvre la
mallette il y à du coton tu en fais de
petites boules et tuent les applique sur
la plaie avec une compresse tu appuies
dessus bertrand de broc mais la blessure
fait 2 cm de long et 5 mm de profondeur
le médecin alors il faut recoudre
d'abord une anesthésie locale utilise le
petit flacon ensuite du pic franchement
et l'autre de s'exécuter
trois heures durant opération réussie
venise les engagés très fortement à
réaliser l'opération tout seul
j'ai quand même moi même avant de lui
proposer ca est réalisée même
l'intervention sera enfin évidemment
coupé à l'engagement mais j'ai pris
l'éguille j'ai essayé je suis devant la
glace et puis j'ai un petit peu piqué la
langue pouvoir c'était vraiment
douloureux et vient pour voir si tout
seul effectivement pouvait faire à
défaut de perdre sa langue bertrand de
broc perd une place ce soir
il vogue en troisième position dans le
sillage d'alain gautier et de philippe
poupon ce soir sur france 2 vers 20